my name is Rosie Lane and I'm a
sophomore studying politics and history
here at Hillsdale College I proudly
serve as a sophomore class
representative to the Hillsdale student
Federation where I'm the chairman of the
publication's can be committee it is my
distinct honor today to present our
speaker miss Pamela Smith Hill Ms Pamela
Smith Hill is an author and lecturer at
Missouri State University she earned her
MA in literature at University of South
Dakota miss Hill is taught professional
and creative writing classes at
universities in Oregon Washington and
Colorado her books have been recognized
by the jr. library guild the Oregon Book
Awards Western Writers of America the
Midwest booksellers women writing the
West New York Public Library the
National Index lence Committee and the
Mark Twain award committee MS hills
online course on Laura Ingalls Wilder
has reached over 8,000 students
worldwide she is the author or editor of
several books including the following a
voice from the border the last rail
keeper Pioneer girl the annotated
autobiography and Laura Ingalls Wilder a
writer's life please join me tonight in
welcoming our distinguished speaker miss
Pamela Smith Hill
thank you very much for the wonderful
introduction thank you all for being
here now if I can make the technology
work
virginia woolf once said my god how does
one write a biography I had a similar
reaction when my editor approached me
about writing a biography of Laura
Ingalls Wilder only my exact words are
the ones you see on the screen my god is
there anything new to say about Laura
Ingalls Wilder everyone knows that Laura
Ingalls Wilder was a sweet little old
lady who started writing in her 60s she
transformed the facts of her life into a
popular children's book series and was
an instant success what more is there to
say about her more about this myth a
little later in the meantime I obviously
said yes to writing a biography about
Wilder why did I attempt to do the
impossible why did I say yes the answer
is autobiographical I first fell under
the spell of biography as a third grader
when I began reading the childhood of
famous American series a fictionalized
series of biographies about mainstream
American heroes and heroines for young
readers these books usually ended when
the title characters were poised on the
threshold of greatness my personal
favorites always focused on girls Martha
Washington Louisa May Alcott Harriet
Beecher Stowe and Sacagawea that's how
we pronounced her name in those days I
was looking for a role model as an
eight-year-old and the idea that these
important and famous girls didn't know
that they were going to do important
things and become famous women intrigued
me the future perhaps even my future was
suddenly full of possibilities I
eventually graduated from the famous
American series two more literary
biographies for young readers this book
Narcissa Whitman pioneer of Oregon by
Jeannette Eaton created a kind of
literary epiphany
me I clearly remember the moment when I
read this passage as a fifth grader
during free reading time after lunch at
Hickory Hills school in Springfield
Missouri at the bottom of the stairs Joe
Lewis was squinting up at her and
several Indians stood in the air she
paused somehow she believed the children
would be saved but for her hate waited
below she shrank from the vision of
violent death beside the form of Marcus
her feet Stood Still was he breathing
before her the face of Joe Lewis thrust
itself and faintness seized her she felt
herself sink forward with her head on
her husband's breast now granted this is
pretty subtle but for the period in
which it was written the book was
published in 1941 and I found it in my
library in 1965 it was an edgy seen in
biography for young readers the death of
the title character and not merely a
quiet death in old age but a violent one
a life cut short too soon I read and
reread the ending to this chapter during
that silent reading period during fifth
grade Shirley nurses and Whitman hadn't
died here surely she lived on with her
husband Marcus and her children but the
meaning was inescapable for the first
time I came away from a book a biography
with a sense of mortality an awareness
that the future was finite even for
famous and important people but getting
back to Laura Ingalls Wilder how did
these books influence my decision to
write a biography about her they
provided me with an introduction to a
literary genre that intrigued and
challenged me writers often write in
genres they love to read poets usually
like to repo
Petre romance writers usually like to
read romances biographers usually like
to read biographies not exclusive of
everything else of course but in general
we're drawn as readers to the genres in
which we write and from my earliest
reading experiences I loved biographies
I believe that childhood reading
experiences can shape our literary
future Nancy McCabe has recently
published a literary memoir based on
this idea that the books we read as
children and young adults continue to
influence us decades later she writes
these books and characters had shaped me
in a thousand surprising small ways but
in larger ones too in them I'd figured
out who I wanted to be found sources of
creativity templates for transcending
limitations and models for leading a
creative life note the line models for
leading a creative life it wasn't just
my love for childhood biographies that
led me to say yes to writing a biography
as an adult about Laura Ingalls Wilder
it was Laura Ingalls Wilder herself who
became my role model for leading a
creative life which brings me to a
second important point about writing
biography biographers should feel some
emotional interest or curiosity that
motivates them to delve into someone
else's life and to become intimately
acquainted with the intimate details of
that person's life that's not to say
that a biographer has to like her
subject although I do think it helps but
a biographer has to have some common
interest some personal stake other than
purely financial or professional one in
exploring someone else's life my
connection to Laura Ingalls Wilder like
so many other Wilder fans and like so
many of the
students I met today when I talked
briefly to a group who was studying
Laura Ingalls Wilder my connection with
her began very early at about the same
time I read Narciso Whitman's biography
I read my first little house novel in
addition to reading biographies and
catching perch with my grandfather
that's me in the middle I like to read
historical fiction another literary
staple for young readers growing up in
the 1940s 50s and 60s I was 10 years old
when I read my first little house book
and the following spring on May 29th
1965 I visited Laura Ingalls Wilder's
home at Rocky Ridge Farm in the Missouri
Ozarks for the first time I had just
recently turned 11 years old how can I
be so sure of that date May 29th 1965
because I wrote about it in this very
diary the first one I ever kept and for
that day I wrote went to Wilder home I
kept the entry short because I was
writing in a five-year diary
and I had only four lines to describe
the entire day but don't let the brevity
of an eleven-year-old fool you
I was completely inspired on that May
Day back in 1965 I'd learned something
that would stay with me throughout my
childhood and adolescent I learned that
someone from the Missouri Ozarks could
publish a book or as my father might say
even a hillbilly can write after all
Wilders farm was just 40 miles from
where I grew up in Springfield Missouri
and Wilder had been a farmer's wife
before she published her first book I
mean look at her in this picture she's
sitting at her dining room table
surrounded by her books wearing an
ordinary house dress just like the ones
my fourth grade teacher mrs. mom
like to wear now up until this moment
when I stood in Laura Ingalls Wilder's
kitchen I always assumed that all real
writers came from New York City and they
looked like this
they wore fashionable suits and had
cigarettes in long cigarette holders
they sipped mysterious alcoholic
beverages from long-stemmed glasses and
they led a generally dissipated big-city
life as a preacher's kid in the Bible
Belt such a life seemed infinitely
intriguing but infinitely unattainable
for someone like me and yet I wanted
with all my heart
even at 11 to become a writer so
standing in Wilders kitchen at Rocky
Ridge Farm in 1965 looking at her
handwritten manuscripts on tablets just
like the ones I used at school this gave
me great hope maybe you didn't have to
become a New Yorker to write and publish
books and then of course there were
Wilders books themselves this is the
first one I read I admire the books
greatly but in those days what
interested me most wasn't the story of
Pama Mary Laura grace and baby Carrie it
was the fact that the main character in
these books went on to become a writer a
future that seemed impossible for her
when she was just about my own age
gather ye rosebuds the poem for Laura
then as they walked on together in the
rose scented warm wind she talked of her
studies in literature I'm planning to
write a book someday she confided then
she laughed but I plan to teach school
and you were doing that for me so maybe
you will write the book I write a book
Laura who did she said blithely I'm
going to be an old maid schoolteacher
like Miss Wilder write your own book
knowing that Laura went on
to write book after book after book even
though she grew up to be a farmer's wife
and lived in the Ozarks this armed me
with possibilities for a creative life
of my own a future that had once seemed
unattainable
I left the Missouri Ozarks when I was in
my 20s and I moved to South Dakota the
setting of five of Wilders nine books I
was well on my way toward a riding
career I'd already been a staff writer
at my hometown newspaper where I'd
worked with a photographer who had taken
many years before that picture of Laura
Ingalls Wilder
in the house dress at her dining room
table I was soon to freelance for the
Sioux City Journal and to write for
state agencies in South Dakota what I
hadn't bargained for however when I
moved to South Dakota was all that big
empty sky this is what I'd been used to
rocky hills low hazy skies the lush
Bluegreen of Missouri when Laura Ingalls
Wilder first saw the Missouri Ozarks in
1894 when she Almanzo and their daughter
Rose first moved to Missouri from South
Dakota
it was the contrast in sky that caught
her eye the sky seems lower here and it
is the softest blue the distances and
the valleys are blue where ever you can
see them it is a drowsy country that
makes you feel wide awake and alive but
somehow contented in 1974 when I moved
from Missouri to South Dakota I
exchanged that soft blue drowsy sky for
this the land stretching flat and almost
treeless in every direction it made me
feel small vulnerable and exposed on my
first day in South Dakota I said on the
curb in front of the big dilapidated old
Victorian house butchered in two
apartments for impoverished college
students and wept whatever had possessed
me to move west
over the next few months I reread Wilder
South Dakota novels her books worked
their magic I embraced the big prairie
sky the alien landscape and discovered
its subtle but somehow dramatic beauty
yet Wilders books did more than heal the
wounds of moving West they began to
teach me about the writing craft and I
came away with a new respect for Wilder
not just as a writer of children's books
but as a writer with a capital W I began
to write professionally about Laura
Ingalls Wilder in the 1970s when I
worked for the South Dakota Division of
Tourism and I met old-timers in De Smet
South Dakota who had known the Ingalls
family and even Laura herself Here I am
at my tourism desk where I wrote many of
these stories and if you look closely
very closely you'll see a photograph of
the Ingalls girls just below the
bulletin board on the right side of the
photograph I kept all of those interview
notes and materials from these stories
as I moved west across the country from
South Dakota to Kansas to Colorado and
finally to Oregon where Charles Ingalls
himself had always hoped to settle I
also began to write fiction for young
adults my fiction is very different than
Wilders little house books but like her
I was first a journalist more about this
in a minute and eventually a novelist so
because of my personal connection I felt
with Wilder and her work I was
immediately attracted to the idea of
writing a biography when the South
Dakota State Historical Society press
first contacted me about it but I knew
the wilder myth and it read the previous
biographies about her and so I hesitated
would I have anything new to say about
her hadn't everything already been said
one more autobiographical note my late
husband who understood Wilders influence
on my childhood and my professional
encouraged me to take on the project
when the offer to write the book came he
was battling stage 4 cancer and while I
was grappling with whether to say yes to
the project we learned his cancer was
unstoppable you'll need this book when
I'm gone he told me during the last
weeks of his life which brings me back
to this idea biographers should feel a
personal connection to their subjects I
said yes to writing a biography of Laura
Ingalls Wilder for myself for my husband
and for all that Laura Ingalls Wilder
had met to me over my lifetime little
did I know however when I said yes just
how important it would be to have a
personal connection with my subject what
I didn't know then but I do know now is
that a biographer subjects become part
of her own life the life of a biographer
and the life of her subject become
intimately intertwined during the
process of researching and writing a
biography if you don't have some kind of
connection with your subject if you
don't feel a bond with her writing a
biography would be unimaginably tedious
and perhaps unimaginably miserable in a
way biographers lead dual lives
simultaneously living their own lives as
they relive the lives of their subjects
when I had knee surgery as I was working
on pioneer girl I realized I was talking
to Laura Ingalls Wilder as I woke up in
the recovery room I'm sure the nurses
there thought I was either absolutely
crazy or absolutely pathetic but back to
biography once I said yes to writing it
I still had to deal with that bigger
question what was I going to say about
Laura Ingalls Wilder that hadn't been
said before
this brings me to another observation
about writing biography biographers must
find a unique and compelling story to
tell a good biography is not simply a
recitation of facts it presents a
compelling and sometimes new
interpretation of a life biographers
sort through facts and attempt to find
meaning in them and from that meaning we
present a slice of meaning about our
subjects lives biographers can't
possibly know everything about the
people we attempt to bring to life to
return to Virginia Woolf
she wrote a fictional biography entitled
Orlando inspired by Vita sackville-west
if you haven't read it I totally
recommend it Woolf often summons up the
voice of a biographer and what his
responsibilities are in this book and in
one of my favorite passages she writes
for Orlando had a great variety of
selves to call upon far more than we
have been able to find room for since a
biography is considered complete if it
merely accounts for six or seven selves
whereas a person may well have as many
as a thousand what wolf is getting at
here is the complexity of individuals
are multiple selves and our multiple
secrets even when a biographical subject
has a vast archival record letters
diaries manuscripts photographs
published works a biographer can only
hint at these complexities our subjects
sometimes willfully hold on to their
secrets sometimes their secrets are
simply inevitably lost and sometimes
what appears as evidence masks deeper
secrets perhaps forever lost to history
what biographers can present however is
an enlightened interpretation of
someone's life a meaningful way to
understand appreciate
or even indict the people whom we choose
to write about and I think finding the
way into an interpretation of life
understanding the scope of biography and
its inherent limitations is what
Virginia Woolf was getting at with that
quote my god how does one write a
biography in a way finding the story you
want to tell as a biographer is about
placing limitations boundaries on
biography about giving yourself and your
readers realistic limitations and
expectations so how do biographers find
a biographies story how do we find the
common thread linking everyday facts
decisions events disappointments
accomplishments people's places all the
selves within an individual how do we
find that common thread the story that
gives an individual biography meaning
and ultimately life the only way I know
how to do that is through research and
it was only through research that I
found my own interpretation of Laura
Ingalls Wilder's life and was finally
able to answer the question that had
haunted me even after I had said yes to
write the book what did I have new to
say about Laura Ingalls Wilder obviously
from the title the emphasis here is on
Wilders writing life now this sounds
obvious doesn't it but previous
biographers hadn't focused on this
aspect of her life hold on to the
thought
how long is it been out hmmm this is
interesting just keep going okay I'll
keep going what's supposed to be up on
the screen is a picture of Laura Ingalls
Wilder's a writer's life to cover so I
don't think you're missing too much
anyway it seems kind of obvious to write
a biography about Laura Ingalls Wilder's
writers life however previous
biographers hadn't focused on this
aspect of Laura Ingalls Wilder instead
they had recounted the events of her
life or examine the social historical or
cultural developments that informed her
life they touched on her writing but
didn't explore it fully and as a reader
of those biographies I come away with
dozens of unanswered questions of my own
I assumed my questions simply couldn't
be answered the previous biographers
hadn't explored this aspect of Wilders
life because she had left behind no
paper trail
other than the rough manuscripts
themselves to illuminate it what I came
to realize however as I launched my own
research was that this absence had yay
hooray had less to do with Wilders paper
trail and more to do with the
professional backgrounds and interests
of Wilders previous biographers such
topics as the creative writing process
the conventions of children's literature
children's publishing or and for me this
was my way into the biography the
editorial process how writers and
editors work together on a piece of
fiction these topics simply hadn't been
on their biographical radar but they
were definitely on mine before I go any
deeper on the subject however I want to
be very clear about something
finding the story and a biography should
be based on research not on previously
held assumptions in other words I didn't
cept the Commission to write this
biography to prove that Laura Ingalls
Wilder was an important or significant
writer are to set the record straight
about her in fact
when I asked my editor my god is there
anything new to say about Laura Ingalls
Wilder she suggested that I focus on the
role South Dakota played in Laura
Ingalls Wilder's life at the time
my editors suggestion reassured me I
wasn't convinced that the South Dakota
theme was right after all Laura Ingalls
Wilder had spent 63 of her 90 years in
Missouri but maybe there was something
else to say about Laura Ingalls Wilder
something new and fresh
I knew my editor well enough to know
that she wouldn't be eager to publish
another biography on Laura Ingalls
Wilder if she didn't think I had
something to say so that silenced the
inner skeptic in me and I launched
preliminary research into the biography
previous biographers had for example
already taken steps to undercut the
established Wilder myth you know the one
about the white-haired the low lady who
started writing in her 60s and was an
instant success in fact Laura Ingalls
Wilder launched a professional writing
career when she was in her 40s riding
for the missouri rural lyst the leading
agricultural newspaper in the state as I
dug deeper however it became clear that
well some Wilder scholars might have
taken this experience or her writing
experience very seriously most did not
Wilder herself however felt her
experience in her days at the missouri
rural aswer very very important
she took her work there quite seriously
even her daughter Rose Wilder Lane had
grudging respect for her mother's work
at the rural list writing to her mother
in 1919 Rose herself was quickly
becoming a recognized contributor to
prominent national magazines of the
period and yet she observed it is
extraordinarily good your rural stuff
always did stand out in the paper like a
skyscraper
on a plane Wilder wrote for the missouri
rural list from 1911 until roughly 1924
breaking in as a columnist and then
eventually becoming a contributing
editor
although wilder was writing for a
regional audience it was a large one in
1918 when Wilder herself was profiled on
the pages of the missouri rural list it
had a circulation of over 88,000 readers
the newspapers editor-in-chief wrote the
profile on wilder for that issue of the
newspaper and observed she knows farm
folks and their problems as few women
who write know them and having sympathy
with the folks whom she serves
she writes well these insights into
Wilders writing life laid the foundation
for my approach to her biography
ultimately however two big chunks of
primary material illuminated my path
toward a deeper interpretation of
Wilders writing life and her literary
legacy before I go further down this
path I want to remind you that when I
launched my research into the biography
of Laura Ingalls Wilder Pioneer girl had
not yet been published in any form so
bear with me I'll talk about pioneer
girl in just a few more minutes what
you're looking at here is pioneer girl
in its original form
Wilders rough draft handwritten
autobiography it was written in 1930
before the Little House novels and it
was written for adult readers not
children or young adults it was clear
from the material in the autobiography
that Wilder had fictionalized her family
history often in dramatic ways to make
her novels more compelling more
appealing and more interesting for young
readers what was also clear from my
review of the rough draft version of
Pioneer girl was that Laura Ingalls
Wilder had considerable writing talent
even in her first rough draft attempt to
write alone
form manuscript I'll talk more about
this later too but in the meantime Laura
Ingalls Wilder understood how to create
memorable characters how to write
believable dialogue and how to build
compelling settings for her work I
should also add that none of Wilders
previous biographers had examined the
rough draft version of Pioneer girl in a
literary or critical way in part because
the rough draft version wasn't easily
accessible and because it was very
difficult to read more about this later
- and the second chunk of primary
research that helped me find the story I
wanted to tell about Laura Ingalls
Wilder the editorial letters between
Wilder and her daughter author Rose
Wilder Lane although previous
biographers and critics had sometimes
quoted from this correspondence none of
them had placed the letters in context
before none of them recognized the
letters for what they were professional
correspondence between an editor and a
writer discussing sometimes arguing
about issues of craft point of view
dialogue characterization what to add
what to cut where manuscripts should
begin and end here for example is Rose
Wilder Lane asking her mother to provide
more vivid concrete details in a scene
that would ultimately become part of on
the banks of Plum Creek oops I want to
go back let's take a look at this more
closely with school in the summer time
in July what school books did Laura and
Mary have what did paw wear when he
dressed up where were the dresses what
were the dresses that grew too short the
ones they wore to school when the boy
called them long-legged Snipes I mean
what material what color how made what
Rose Wilder Lane is getting out here is
a basic principle for all of you people
who are interested in creative writing
it's show don't tell provide a series of
details so readers can visualize a scene
more clearly and here's a second example
which illustrates how Wilder argued back
with her daughter this time about
whether to cut Mary's blindness from the
little house books Lane thought Mary's
blindness would be too grim and tragic
for young readers Wilder thought
passionately to keep it a touch of
tragedy she wrote makes the story truer
to life and showing the way we took it
illustrates the spirit of the times
and the frontier I think most of us who
know Wilders work are really glad Wilder
won this editorial argument this is a
routine part of the publishing process
editorial letters go back and forth
between an editor and a writer now it's
usually emails not letters but the
content is pretty much the same and this
kind of correspondence occurs whether
the genre is fiction or nonfiction
whether the work dates from 1930 or 2016
in case you need some convincing here is
an example of an excerpt from a letter I
received from my own editor many years
ago as I was writing and revising my
young adult novel about the American
Civil War a voice from the border I'm
going to show you one excerpt keep in
mind that this excerpt was one of about
a dozen letters I received about the
book and this particular excerpt is from
a letter that ran three pages long
single spaced typewritten sometimes
there's dialogue that isn't up to the
level of the rest of the novel it should
be considered more obvious not as rich
or specific as other dialogue there are
times when Mama's dialogue and high room
speech don't quite hit the mark or even
daddy's I'm not quite convinced that
people would talk in such a way keep an
eye out for dialogue that is perhaps a
bit too high-minded and where possible
just cut it
this letter is about craft the editorial
direction a novel will take and that's
exactly what wilder and lane were
writing to each other about and
1930s and 1940s there was nothing
exceptional about this correspondence
except that these editorial letters were
between a mother and a daughter and that
Wilders publisher Harper & Brothers
apparently didn't know anything about it
whoops
none of the manuscripts ever needed any
editing not any this is a quotation from
Ursula Nordstrom Wilders last editor at
Harper & Brothers obviously if you look
at the correspondence and the
manuscripts of the little house books
it's clear that they were edited
it's just that Wilders primary editor
wasn't employed by her publisher Wilders
editor was her daughter working from
home in secret a secret wilder and lane
didn't share with the editorial staff at
Harper & Brothers so there was my story
a new interpretation of Wilders writing
life that grew out of my research one
more point about this I believe
biographers should keep an open mind as
we're conducting preliminary research
and throughout the entire research
process if you have an agenda when you
take on a biographical project then
you're less likely to interpret research
findings fairly and honestly and I
firmly believe that we as biographers oh
it to our subjects and to our readers to
do just that now obviously I found the
story I wanted to tell about Laura
Ingalls Wilder and the book was
published in 2007 but I had unfinished
business with mrs. Wilder and Pioneer
girl though I didn't know it at the time
when I'm researching a book whether it's
nonfiction or fiction I use the same
techniques I serve a secondary materials
I review primary sources I conduct
interviews I go online
review a variety of source material and
I do location or archival research these
are arbitrary categories and sometimes
they overlap archival research for
example is often done on location and is
focused on primary materials and this is
exactly how pioneer girl began while I
was researching writers life viewing
archival materials on location in the
Herbert Hoover Presidential Library in
West Branch Iowa the archive room there
is very small and only the archivist and
I were at work in that room on an
afternoon in 2006 the phone rang I
overheard the archivist explaining to
the caller which versions of Pioneer
girl were housed at the Museum and how
the caller could get a Xerox copy of one
of them was that under the wilder
scholar I asked when the archivist hung
up the phone no he said another Wilder
fan we get dozens of these calls every
year everybody wants a copy of Pioneer
girl
writers life quoted extensively from the
rough draft version of Pioneer girl and
after the book was published I began to
hear from readers who wanted to know how
they could get a copy of Pioneer girl
for themselves
another Wilder scholar even asked me to
make a Xerox copy of my Xerox copy and
send it to him so in 2009 I emailed my
editor at the South Dakota State
Historical Society press and proposed an
annotated version of Pioneer girl she
agreed immediately at the time we both
thought the book would be an obscure
scholarly work that would appeal to a
very small audience made up of primarily
diehard Wilder fans and scholars why an
annotated version here we are back
looking at the original manuscripts
again but I have to tell you that there
really isn't a definitive version
pioneer girl when I wrote writers life I
worked from a Xerox copy of these
originals taken from a microfilm
image housed at the University of
Missouri in Columbia this is not a bad
slide this is actually a very good
representation of what the original
pioneer growing manuscript looks like on
microfilm now look at that little slice
think about going through all of those
Big Chief tablets when the manuscript
looks like that
now this particular manuscript was not
housed at the Herbert Hoover
Presidential Library it's in a secure
climate-controlled location in Mansfield
Missouri I didn't actually see the
original pioneer girl manuscript until I
was at work on the annotated
autobiography and I can tell you the
original manuscript is incredibly
fragile as are all of the original
little house manuscripts the remaining
versions the typewritten versions of
Pioneer girl are edited and most of them
are available through the Herbert Hoover
Presidential Library and because most of
them because these other versions are
typewritten it's much easier to read
them and that's why previous biographers
had focused on the edited versions they
were typewritten they didn't have to
sort through page after page after page
of micro filmed handwritten manuscript
furthermore the remaining typewritten
edited versions of Pioneer girl are the
result of the collaboration between
Laura Ingalls Wilder and Rose Wilder
Lane
and there are significant differences
between those various typewritten
versions a subject I address more
directly in Pioneer girl I'll touch on a
few of these differences in a moment but
because pioneer girl wasn't published
during Wilders lifetime there really
isn't a definitive version of her
autobiography she finished the rough
draft in May 1930 and showed it to Layne
who recorded this incident in her diary
my mother came in the afternoon bringing
her manuscript she and Papa stayed to
dinner later that week Layne typed to
the manuscript making minor punctuation
and spelling changes and sent it off to
her literary agent in New York the idea
was to sell pioneer girl to a prominent
magazine like The Saturday Evening Post
or the Ladies Home Journal and if it
succeeded as a serial in one of these
popular magazines perhaps Wilder would
then land a separate book contract she
and Lane essentially hoped the
manuscript would sell twice of course it
didn't sell at all
but during 1930 the women worked
together to revise and rewrite pioneer
girls several times hoping a later more
polished version would appeal to a
magazine editor so under the
circumstances an annotated 21st century
version of Pioneer girl which would put
all the versions in context and compare
the various pioneer girl texts with
Laura Ingalls Wilder's on the house
books seem to me to be the best approach
and I chose to use Wilders rough draft
manuscript with its inevitable
misspellings false starts and
punctuation errors the kinds of
discrepancies you would find in any
rough draft manuscript because it gave
wilder readers a look at her
unadulterated unedited voice pioneer
girl gives us pure Laura Ingalls Wilder
this was important I thought because of
the ongoing controversy about authorship
of the little house books and the
contention that Rose Wilder Lane had
actually written them I mentioned
earlier today that Pine
girl illustrates Wilders raw writing
talent let's look at one passage in
particular here's that passage I just
showed you a few moments ago this is
Laura Ingalls Wilder's handwriting by
the way and here's what the passage says
the Sun sank lower and lower until
looking like a bowl of pulsing liquid
light its saint gloriously in clouds of
crimson and silver gold purple shadows
rose in the east crest crept slowly over
the horizon then gathered above in depth
on depth of darkness from which the
stars swung low and bright this is rough
draft unedited Laura Ingalls Wilder you
tell me if you think she can write still
one isolated passage in a book length
manuscript doesn't necessarily still one
isolated passage in a book length
manuscript doesn't necessarily translate
to sustained talent and yet this passage
in Pioneer girl is revealing because it
appears in a slightly different form in
the final adult version of Pioneer girl
which was edited by Rose Wilder Lane
let's take a look at that passage the
Sun sank lower and lower still a ball of
pulsing liquid light its sank in clouds
of crimson and silver now the Edit isn't
radical here and yet the passage has
lost its original poetic rhythm and
grace it was better as Wilder originally
wrote it but there's more Wilders
original descriptive passage from
Pioneer girl went on to have yet another
life this time in her novel by the
shores of Silver Lake here's how it
appears in this book the Sun sank a ball
of pulsing liquid light it's saying in
clouds of crimson and silver again the
Edit is very subtle but it too lacks the
originals lyric rhythm and yet except
for these opening lines the two lines
you see here
while to return to her original passage
in Pioneer girl for the rest of the
description as it appears and by the
shores of Silver Lake
perhaps because by then her confidence
in her own work had grown and she wasn't
relying as heavily on her daughter's
editorial advice let's take one more
look at this original passage from
Pioneer girl the Sun sank lower and
lower until looking like a ball of
pulsing liquid light it's a gloriously
in clouds of crimson and silver the
original line has movement both in the
scene it describes and the rhythm of the
words furthermore for all you writing
geeks out there wilder uses an adverb in
the scene the word gloriously now in
general adverbs are not a writer's
friend but Wilder uses it brilliantly
and perfectly here now bear with me for
just a moment more because this passage
had yet another life this time in Rose
Wilder Lane Pioneer novel free land
which borrowed heavily from pioneer girl
it was published in 1938 and here's
Lane's take on Wilders original passage
sunset spread in rainbow colors around
the level rim of the earth and purple
shadows Rose the low stars were huge and
quivering the description is frankly
prosaic flat and dull it lacks the
visual immediacy and impact of her
mother's rough draft original passage if
Rose Wilder Lane was truly the ghost
writer of the little house books why did
her pioneer novels lack the lyricism
beauty and distinctive voice readers
find in many original passages in
pioneer girl as well as throughout the
Little House series this is why I felt
it was important to give readers a
chance to make up their own mind about
this issue by sharing the rough draft
original version of Pioneer girl still I
also believed in Pioneer girl that it
was important to showcase different
is between Wilders rough-draft
autobiography and the edited versions
especially when they revealed something
about Wilders literary instincts and/or
her daughters I'll share just one with
you today but it's important because it
strikes at the issue of authenticity and
autobiographical writing let's start
first with a brief definition one that
for the most part applies to pioneer
girl autobiographical writing is really
a kind of hybrid form with elements of
both fiction and essay in which the
author's voice musing conversationally
on a true story is all-important or to
paraphrase autobiographical writing
relates a true story drawn from the
writers life in other words while
autobiographical writing may borrow
elements from fiction by recreating
believable dialogue controlling the pace
and tension between scenes even moving
forward and backward in time an
autobiography is true drawn from a
writers real-life experiences and yet
the final edited version of pioneer girl
prepared late in 1930 and marketed to
the Saturday Evening Post among other
magazines contained a fictional story
about the Ingalls family's brush with
the notorious nineteenth-century mass
murderers the Bender's of Kansas the
Bender's were accused of mass murder on
the Kansas frontier in the 1870s and
although their case was never resolved
newspapers ran grisly story after grisly
story about these presumed criminals
readers in the 1930s would have been
familiar with the case in the final
edited version of pioneer girl wilder
and lane placed a bender episode on page
7 where it would be sure to get a
magazine editors attention right away in
their version of the Bender's tale
Charles Ingalls rides with vigilantes in
Kansas to track down and punish the
Bender's Wilders invented or perhaps
Gumble childhood memory of the scene is
poignant and harrowing for a long time
even four years after that I dream
sometimes about a little girl thrown on
top of her mother and father and buried
alive sometimes I was the little girl
the only problem with this story the
Ingalls family left Kansas or Indian
Territory in 1871 the first murder
charges against the Bender's date from
1873 two years later Charles Ingalls
couldn't possibly have ridden with those
vigilantes even if they had written
after the Bender's because he and his
family were living in Wisconsin at the
time so how did this episode clearly
fictional clearly invented find its way
into the final draft of Pioneer girl an
autobiography I discussed this much more
fully in Pioneer girl but I will say
this rosewater Lane was eager to sell
her mother's autobiography remember it
was 1930 the Great Depression had
deepened and money was tight on Rocky
Ridge Farm Lane one of a handful of
successful American women writers at the
time was having trouble selling her own
manuscripts living at Rocky Ridge Farm
with her parents and her companion Helen
Boylston Lane believed that selling
pioneer girl might ease their financial
distress a story about the Bender's
could make her mother's manuscript much
more marketable and just one more detail
as I discussed in Pioneer girl Lane had
a history of writing fictional episodes
into her own nonfiction and Laura
Ingalls Wilder seemed to approve of this
approach the addition of the Bender's
episode in later edited versions of
Pioneer girl illustrates an ongoing
argument about memoir
Autobiography are these works true and
factual or are they fiction are they
invented from Lillian Hellman's
Pentimento to James fries a million
little pieces and Margaret's ulcers love
and consequences the controversy over
fact versus fiction in memoir and
autobiography continues to polarize
readers writers and editors alike as
Mary McCarthy wrote in a very famous
quote about Pentimento every word she
writes as a lie
including and and though or is it as
Barrington points out if you can make up
dialogue change the name and hair color
of a character to protect the privacy of
the living or even as some memoirs do
reorder the events of the story to make
it work better how is that different
from fiction
I'd love to hear what all of you have to
think about this dilemma later on and
one final observation about writing both
biography and memoir readers need to
know when your research is contradictory
or inconclusive let your readers share
this experience as biographers or
memoirs we should trust our readers with
the ambiguity of research a prime
example from Pioneer girl
Wilders age when she started teaching
school in Pioneer girl and in these
happy golden years Laura is 15 when she
first teaches school at that unfortunate
buteo Brewster school in Dakota
Territory in editorial correspondence
with lane Wilder seems convinced that
she was 15 yet her teaching certificate
is dated December 10th 1883 when Wilder
herself was 16 now I wrote a lengthy
annotation in the annotated
autobiography about this discrepancy
presenting information from both sides
of the issue and they let readers draw
their own conclusion but ultimately
regardless of whether Wilder was 15 or
16 when she first taught school she was
an underage teacher for most of her
teaching career and the county
superintendent overlooked the
territories stated public education
policy when he granted Wilder a teaching
certificate
so in the end it doesn't really matter
whether she was 15 or 16 she was
underage regardless I opened the
discussion today with that quote from
Virginia Woolf my god how does one write
a biography I came across the quotation
in one of my favorite biographies
Hermione Lee's Virginia Woolf in the
closing paragraphs of this book Lee
visits Virginia Wolf's home and writes
that she felt like a biographer a
tourist and an intruder I felt much the
same way when I stood in Laura Ingalls
Wilder's library at Rocky Ridge Farm on
my last visit there in 2014 when I was
with a film crew filming for my massive
open online Wilder class for me the
barriers to keep tourists off the carpet
had been removed for me I took books off
Wilders library shelf I scanned the
titles and then I glanced out the window
for the view stormy skies over an Ozark
landscape brown oak leaves clinging to
the trees a flame of orange sumac here
and there it was a view I thought that
had changed very little in the last 55
years and for that one moment that one
sliver in time it was perhaps a Wilder
herself and intruder or not I was
grateful
I think we have some time for questions
miss Hill has agreed to sign copies of
her book Laura Ingalls Wilder a writer's
life immediately following this session
in the Phillips lobby we have time for a
few questions please stand when the
microphone gets to you hi Paul Krebs hi
I just have to say that I really
appreciate the way organized your ear
lecture oh you're very articulate and
compelling so thank you so much for
being here thank you you know one thing
I noticed was you stated that in general
adverbs are not the writers friend yes
for writers or would-be writers could
you explain a little bit about why you
said that
I think it's if you want to write really
active compelling prose the your best
bet is to find a strong active verb
adverbs are there to kind of help along
a weaker verb if you can choose a strong
verb in the first place you won't need
the adverb but in the case that I just
showed you
Wilder does use an adverb eautifully I
think a lot of beginning writers focus
on using adverbs and adjectives
particularly in description and if you
study Laura Ingalls Wilder's writing
you'll find that although she does use
an adverb occasionally most often how
she describes a setting and why it
becomes so vivid it's because she uses
so many verbs
she makes the setting very active and
very real and so it doesn't it feels
left like description and more like a
character and we can talk more about
that later if you want question
um I was just sort of wondering because
you focused a lot on the relationship
between rose and her mother and I
haven't actually heard a lot about that
but I've read the books and grown up
reading the books and I'm just sort of
wondering like how you have come to view
their relationship like what was the
dynamic between the two of them it seems
as though Rose was trying to criticize
and cut down her mother's very poetic
and artistic writing so I'm just sort of
I'm curious to hear the conclusion that
you've come to about the relationship
between the two of them and also - I
want I wanted to point out that the
blind scene when Laura Ingalls Wilder
talks about how it affected her when she
was growing up was so touching and I
just remember my mom and all my sisters
and I we were sitting there reading it
and it actually brought tears to all of
our eyes so if that would have been
taken out you know some of those
beautiful memories that people have with
the books wouldn't have even happened so
and just thank you so much for being
here
thank you yeah we have really two issues
so I'm going to talk just briefly about
the blindness issue when I met with the
students today we touched on it briefly
but what we tend to forget about Lauren
was Wilder because she has become such
an institution in children's literature
is that she broke all kinds of rules
back in the 1930s and 1940s and she
often broke those rules over her
daughter's editorial advice Rose was all
for about being safe and not taking huge
creative risks because after all if you
kind of went with the Crouch certainly
those books would sell and they needed
the income but the issue of blindness in
fact the issue of continuing with Laura
as the main character Rose wanted to
switch to Carrie when Laura was 13 she
thought Laura would be dealing with
issues that were too adult all of those
kinds of creative leaps we now take for
granted in children's and young adult
literature so Laura Ingalls Wilder was
blazing a new tree
and why while we may think those books
are relatively safe and tame and easy
today
they were very controversial in their
own right and for those of you who love
Laura Ingalls Wilder's books and know
them well you all know that butcher's
scene but your knife scene in these
happy golden years Laura Ingalls
Wilder's editor norts Ursula Nordstrom
wanted to cut that scene and to Ursula
Nordstrom's credit she was an innovator
in children's books she edited EB white
of Charlotte's Web Fame and Maurice
Sendak of where the wild things are but
back in the 1940s she thought that
butcher knife scene was way too
controversial and so Laura's welder
fought to keep that in and I think we
need to remember that as for those of us
who love childrens and why a literature
the genres owe a great debt to Laura
Ingalls Wilder now I could talk for the
rest of the day about the relationship
between
very much